almost famous was such a good movie and
you got nominated for an academy award
and everything which is
unbelievable since like the yucky had
only done like one other film
and then you got that film right and
yeah you had to audition for that i
assume
yeah like four times and tons of people
wanted that
right i mean yeah it was that that was a
that was a uh
i was actually i was shooting in in um
in ireland another film at the time and
i kept flying back and forth to uh
to audition and yeah and i finally
yeah i remember i'll never forget that
phone call but
when i got the part yeah cause i was
supposed to play a different role
i was supposed to play the sister not
penny lane and cameron didn't want me to
audition
so cause he just saw me as the sister
right
and i just said look i'm and then
everybody fell out of the movie because
at the time i got the sister it was brad
pitt and sarah paulie
really and i was turning down other
parts and things and cameron and i said
just please i'm gonna be in the movie
unit but just please
let me audition for why because you
sensed that it would be a big commercial
success
no i just love cameron crowe i loved his
movies they
to me like singles and say anything and
and and jerry maguire i mean to be in to
be in his next film was like
a you know please man were you nervous
when you got on set for that movie
i think you're always a little bit
nervous are you even standing and then
and then you're
oh yeah you get i mean you get anxiety
it's like coming in here you get a
little bit like
and then you sort of start to like you
know get a little more comfortable
yeah but you don't want to get too
comfortable look at the list of people
who were up for that role
i don't know if you ever heard this so
maybe it's not even true because you
just read this stuff okay
uh kate campbell jenna elfman bridget
moynihan maggie gyllenhaal
rose mcgowan rebecca romain auditioned
for the role of penny lane and you beat
them all
is there some sort of like competitive
uh i don't know
pride in all of that you know i think
when you grow up
like with parents like i did
competitiveness in this world
is like a no-no like you get it right
away you know
and and kurt was really great with that
stuff when we were growing up because
why are you just gonna get caught up in
it well i i just think he was
he's so he's so on
honest he's so brutally honest right um
you love him
i love him right so much he's just a
great guy
and he's an original he's very different
you know he's not he doesn't
buy into things did he advise you in
your acting career no
no he didn't no were they freaked out
that you wanted to become an actress
where they were like listen you really
don't want this no
they they knew before i knew you know
what i mean like i think and
now that i have kids like you know when
they're performing when they're
performance oriented you know
and i really did come out like if there
was i mean you had the body i'm
yeah i'm a ham i mean i you know i see a
spotlight i still like that like i see
light and i'm like
and yeah you know i yeah but the thing
that disturbed you growing up
you said when you were around 12 years
old you'd go out
to a i don't know somewhere with your
mom and you'd be in public
and it embarrassed you that she would
get so much attention you didn't like it
i didn't like it yeah i don't blame you
now that you have kids
are you super and hyper aware of that
but how do you
like if i say you know you know in the
street i'm not the type that would
bother someone but i mean
fans are going to come up to you are you
thinking oh i have to control this
situation for my kid
you know my parents always had the best
thing when we were with them and they
were just like
you know you know really kind just would
say not when
i'm with my kids yeah and i think that
kind of made us feel like
a you know i think it can it can get
overwhelming when you're little
when you started acting did you feel
competitive with your mother i felt the
opposite
the truth is like i do have a family
that is
an encouraging family so for us we grew
up with
parents that would only ever want all of
us kids
to be better at anything than them
you know you don't think it was hard for
your mother and maybe even kurt when you
got nominated for an academy award
no i think they were they were relieved
very
you know what that's that's interesting
yeah probably
you're probably worried about it there
was probably a relief of like
you know you know maybe the relief was
like
she's pretty good right not just
validation you know we're not
dropping [ __ ] at all right yeah when you
got tapped for almost famous
and you got them rolled is who do you
call first to tell them that you got the
role
they were i called every you know i i
think it's called the house you know i
just called the
um and they were both there when you did
it
did you do you go to the premieres do
you watch yourself on screen
i hate watching myself really yeah i
have a really hard time with it so if
there's anything i get like sweaty
and i get you won't watch it just to
learn sometimes i mean i guess with i
guess like
there's certain one like i watched
almost famous with ryder just recently
right which was really fun was he in
other words he had never seen
that movie well he's 12 you know it's a
rated r movie right um
so he finally just said mom come on you
know and i was like all right
let me let me see what you're up to and
it was interesting to see how it held up
too with
young like a 12 year old and he was like
out of his mind
yeah he loved it he loved it